when I was a child my brother would tell
me a bedtime story
about the man who murdered our Father
hey everybody it's Charlie this is going to
be my Game of Thrones season 8 episode 2 videos everybody grab your Valyrian
swords or dragonglass weapons here we go I'm doing Game of Thrones videos all
season long be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're new to the channel
and we're also doing a new round that
HBO now giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video careful for
spoilers from episode 2 obviously we do
top 10 and Easter eggs from the
books starting with number 15 the trial
of Jamie Lannister a nice mere 40 Ria's
trial during season 4 and Cersei having
to take the walk of shame all of the
Lannister children now have been held to
task for their past misdeeds Tyrion is
really the only one of them who was on
trial for a crime that he did not commit
although he had plenty of past misdeeds
that he was not being tried for there
were all kinds of references from
Daenerys to him becoming the Kingslayer
you my father
apparently Viserys told her a lot of
stories about Jaime when she was young
you promised me an army all I see before
me is one man with one hand everybody
seems like they're trying to set Jaime
off but he takes it really calmly until
brand gave him that record drop moment
just like he gave a little finger during
season 7 chaos is a ladder in Jamie's
case it was the quote that he gave him
before he pushed him out the window the
things I do for love they call out the
fact several times during the episode
the Jaime has been on the opposite side
or enemies with pretty much everybody in
this room like we here all at one point
wanted to the Starks now we're here
defending it when they're sitting around
the heart at the end of the episode
think about how pissed Tywin Lannister
would be if you were alive to see them
do this which i think is also a nice
name drop from Tyrion reminding you
about bronze secret mission to
assassinate them with the crossbow he
used to Tywin during season four
important detail - according to Jaime
the golden company truce the Cersei has
give or take 20,000 - the ones that
you're on is already she'll have
enough people to defeat anyone who
survives the battle with the White
Walkers during episode three next week
or at least Jaime thinks so unless
there's some other big twist which I
talked about towards the end of this
video when I start talking about the
White Walkers I think there's going to be a
big twist with the night king and I
don't think he's going to do what you
expect him to do like bran was trying to
concoct
this plan to lure him out into the open
there's a really important reason why I
don't think that's going to work
I love the Jamie refused to apologize
for the Mad King I'd do it again
in a second I was protecting my family
my house he refuses to apologize to
Sansa for taking in Ned Stark
I was acting under orders it was time of
war I did what I needed to do but later
in the episode he opens his conversation
with bran by apologizing for pushing him
out the window
14 though was just setting up the
Brienne Jaime arc during the season they
have one of the most compelling
relationships on the show I know there's
all this torment stuff and they're using
for comedy in the background the big
woman's do that but really I think it's
all about Brienne and Jamie's
relationship so I'll talk about what
that is because it's not quite the same
thing as Gendry and Arya's relationship
or Jon Snow it's an Eris's relationship
I think the show has just done a lot
more work establishing their
relationship than say like Jon Snow and
Daenerys whose relationship which they
kind of sped through season seven like
they meet and then a couple episodes
later they're deeply in love they were a
lot of callbacks stirring Brienne's
testimony all the way back to season
three he protected me at the cost of his
hand that was Locke's group during
season three and Brienne also very aptly
puts that the only reason why salsa is
alive because of an oath that Jamie
swore to Catelyn Stark to help find her
children and bring them home which is
why he gave Brienne Oathkeeper and her
armor and set her off on her way the way
Sansa explained it during the episode
though is that she trusts Brienne and
Brienne trusts Jamie it's not this Sansa
trust Jamie she's willing to give him
the benefit of the doubt based on
brand's testimony and because of the
Cersei twist almost none of them are
listening to Tyrion so he's kind of on
the outs for most of the episode number
13 Jaime and brands reunion in the
godswood so this is sort of brand
telling Jaime that he only could become
the man he is today
if he had pushed bran out the window if
he had not he would still be the golden
trash bag character that he was at the
beginning of season one it doesn't
absolve Jaime of any of his guilt and he
has this really funny reaction to brand
when Brant explains how he's not brand
stark anymore I'm kind of the three-eyed
Raven it's the same quizzical look that
sanso had on her face when bran
told the same thing to her I don't know
what that means three-eyed Raven what's
that even though bran has green sight
and he probably has an idea for what
Jaime's role is specifically he doesn't
come right
and tell him and I love the way they
leave their conversation - is that why
should you worry about whether or not
I'm going to tell anyone the truth about
what you did to me because we all might
die tomorrow so what would it matter
after that so you almost get a version
of that same extreme Jamie reaction face
that you got at the end of episode 1
when he first noticed brand like oh my
god
but number 12 Jamie and Tyrians reunion
they have a funny moment just remarking
about how things have changed so much
since the pilot episode remember the
last time we were here my golden days
are behind me
Tyrion says his whoring days are behind
him and they have that funny moment
where the stark soldiers on the balcony
just spit down at them but turns out
they also kind of hate Daenerys - so
Tyrion tries to reassure Jaime like
things aren't quite so bad they sort of
reflect on Jaime's relationship with
Cersei and Tyrion actually quotes
himself from earlier on the show so when
he talks about the way that he wants to
die
when I'm 80 years old in my bed so on
and so forth that was actually a line of
dialogue from way back I think it was
either season one or season two when he
was talking to the crow hills clans of
the Vale when he was with Bronn they got
captured he was trying to talk the storm
crows into taking him back to Tywin for
a really big reward the weird thing
about Tyrion in the episode - is that
there were a couple of different
conversations that he had where he
talked about his own death as if he's
prophesying his own death before the end
of the series so just watch out for him
any character that talks about their own
death that much is probably going to wind
up dying at some point number 11 was
Jaime and Brienne Sri Union in the yard
they have a conversation about pod which
seems kind of funny but really it's a
metaphor for what's going on with Jaime
during this season so Jaime says he's
come a long way but Brienne says he's
still got a lot to learn just saying
that you know even though Jaime is doing
the right thing now trying to be
honorable he still has a long way to go
before he completely redeems himself
Brienne stops him short as they're
talking about battle planning
why aren't you insulting me and it's
sort of them acknowledging the air
between them where they left things last
time where they know that they care
about each other but because neither one
of them is completely prepared to
directly address the way they feel about
each other she just kind of pushes them
away and it gets even more tense towards
the end of the episode but I do feel
like the two of them later in the
episode probably had one of the best
scenes in the entire episode number ten
was Daenerys versus Sansa so this
actually lets you know about what's
going to be happening after the big
battle of winter
like what happens when we defeat the
night king there's still going to be a lot
of problems to solve they're both
wearing their new outfits Sansa has her
new leather armor on Daenerys has the
new fur lined dress they make remarks
about families being very complicated
obvious set up for the R + L equals J
info bomb that John is getting ready to
drop on her the fact that it's just
going to complicate both of their families
Stark and Targaryen they make a joke
about Jon Snow being short because she
was talking about Khal Drogo who was the
man that you loved before John she talks
about someone who was taller that was
Khal Drogo that she was referring to but
the real tension between the two of
those characters is all about what
happens to the north after they win the
battle of defeat Cersei and put Daenerys
on the Iron Throne
Sansa once continued independence for
the north after the Battle of Daenerys
clearly isn't ready to offer that to her
so they're going to have to circle back
around to that after the big battle to
address it before the finale the reason
they're cut short though is actually
great number 9 Theon in sonses reunion
this is actually one of the more
touching reunions in the episode it
reminds you of the beginning of season 6
when they first escaped Winterfell
together so there were actually a couple
really good Sansa Theon scenes during
the episode she seems like she cares
about him a lot the whole reason he came
back though is obviously to atone for
what he did he even references it later
when brand explains his plan for
bringing the night came out in the open
and the gods would let me defend you
with the Ironborn so it's sort of him
atoning for sacking Winterfell during
season two but like I said I think
there's going to be a big twist with bran's
special plan in the night King I don't
think it's going to work so I don't think
things are going to go down the way they
think they will number eight though Jon
Snow's reunion with edy and torment so
this is actually just a funny moment
where he sees edy and the music swells
up but torment almost tackles him out of
frame before he can hug edy torment was
like the master blocker of this episode
like he shows up just to make things
awkward with Brienne and Jaime later in
the episode he stops Jon Snow from
hooking edie torment is a master at
stepping in between people the whole
point of this scene though was just to
catch everyone up to speed about what
happened the last hearth r.i.p a little
Lord umber and they basically say that
anyone who hasn't already made it to
Winterfell
like the Glovers over in Deepwood Motte
they're already part of the army of the
Dead so I think that's a way to say that
by the time the White Walkers have shown
up at the end of the episode
walk into frame they've already hit
Deepwood Motte so
all the Glovers are somewhere walking
around with the other whites in the
background but number seven the big
battle planning scene so this is montage
Jon Snow giving voiceover an
inspirational battle planning speech
while they all show off the defense's
around Winterfell he explains that they
only need to the night king to stop
the entire army of the Dead in the other
White Walkers so that's when brand
launches into his big explainer the
really cool extra new detail we get I
don't know if this is a book thing that
George RR Martin helped them with or if
this is just the showrunners sort of
coming up with this on the fly is that
they say that the three-eyed Raven is
one of many in a line of three-eyed
Ravens that the knight king has been
trying to up to this point so the
main target as we all suspected earlier
this season is brand himself the actor
that plays the night king before the
season started did a big interview where
he says oh I have a target during the
season the night king is coming for
someone you'll learn what it is but
number six Brant explains his plan for
luring him out into the open now Brian
seems like he's assuming that the night
king is going to come to Winterfell but
I actually don't think that he's going to
show up because what happens at the end
of the episode when the White Walkers
walk into frame on their horses you
don't see the night king anywhere and
you don't hear the dragon screeching or
flying in the background so for all we
know the night king has turned around
and gone down to King's Landing to try
and start creating White's down there so
that they have to fight a war on two
fronts instead of just this Battle of
Winterfell
but brands plan is to just wait for him
in the godswood and use himself as bait
so that's the omen Theon jumps in and
says we'll protect you but like I said I
don't think that it's going to go down the
way they expected to Brandon samwell's
explanation for why the night king wants
to him is a little more eloquent
but it actually does line up with most
people's fan theories just that the
night king wants to bring winter to the
entire world a never-ending winter
that's why they call it the long night
he wants to end man as a species in bran
says the reason why he wants to him
because he's a living memory of
everything that's happened in the world
so you him you memories of
that then Samwell launches into a much
more eloquent explainer for it all which
may be set up for that Lord of the Ring
style twist that everyone was joking
about last season what if Samwell is the
one to write the book about what just
happened and he calls it a Song of Ice
and Fire
Samwell says that's what death is
forgetting being forgotten in the way
that you do not
forget is that you write stories down so
hopefully they won't be quite so on the
knows about it Allah Lord of the Rings
but let me know in the comments if you
actually think that that's going to happen
based on what Samwell is saying in this
moment there are a couple really great
smaller scenes with a lot of the
characters having moments together like
you have the Nights Watch brothers
standing on the battlements like they
stood on the wall during season one
Samwell talking to it and Jon Snow then
sort of poking fun at Sam well Samwell
slayer of White Walkers lover of ladies
we're really screwed now if this would
it's come to they try to give all the
main characters moments like this like
you have the surge or a moment with a
little bear where she tells him I wish
you good fortune in the wars to come and
he's like okay fine because she doesn't
want to hide down in the crypts with
everyone else so we did finally get a
surge or a little bear scene but that's
probably going to be the extent of it I
don't expect them to get a whole lot of
time together number five was everyone
around the hearth even though they tried
to play it really comedic Lee there were
a couple really great moments it went a
little over the top with tormund
explaining himself like do you know how
I got the name tormund Giantsbane
a giant when I was 10 climbed in bed
with his wife in the giantess
thought I was her child suckled me at
her teat for three months that's why I
got so strong Giants milk and they just
go ups a whole bunch of it down from his
horn they're the funniest thing about
this scene though is actually Brienne's
horrified reaction you just see her
speechless they're just trying to take
it all in oh my god what did I just hear
and during all those moments where he
was trying to proposition Brienne you
could actually see her in frame wit
Jamie just out of focus in the budget
sort of their way of addressing the
funny love triangle that's been
happening for the past couple of seasons
but like I said I think this is all
about Jaime and Brienne
they've been setting that up ever since
season 3 ever since he explained why he
became the Kingslayer number four was
arias second reunion with the Hound
which was a little more personal but
they also got the ring in with barek who
she hasn't seen since season three I
love the way she checked him too
what are you doing here you've never
fought from anyone but yourself and then
he remarks I fought for you didn't I
which is a way to show you that they
both come a long way he's actually being
more honorable being a good person she's
kind of gone in the opposite direction
even though she is fairly well adjusted
she's a stone-cold at this point
they drop a really big red wedding
reference when Barrack walks up into how
it gets really pissed off oh we might as
well be at a bloody wedding which at the
end of season 3 they walked up at the
Quinn's right after the red wedding had
gone down aurilla lets us know that
Barrack isn't on her list anymore I
think that happened during season six
when the wake was questioning him it was
just a really way of acknowledging how
Oriya cared about the hound at that
point number three though was Orion
Gendry finally doing the deed as awkward
as possible as you would expect from a
couple people like that Arya's first
time I would want to die without
experiencing this so let's just get it
on get it over with
I'm not the red woman take your own damn
pants off she seems a little surprised
when he tells her about his true origin
I'm Robert Baratheon's bastard but I
don't think that mattered to her before
so I don't think that it really changes
anything about the way she feels about
Gendry the other really interesting
thing too about their scene is that when
she's taking her clothes off Gendry
notices all of her scars from her
training it's the same kind of look that
Daenerys gave John Snow
when she saw all of his scars during
season 7 episode 6 like wow what
happened there there's clearly a story
behind all those scars number two though
obviously was Jamie knighting Brienne if
you didn't recognize they were actually
playing the same soundtrack from when he
gave her oath keeper even though it
sounded like an oath keeper theme song
the name of the song is actually called
Kingslayer so it started out as a Jamie
Lannister theme then once they got to
season four their relationship had
blossomed a little bit more it turned
into a theme for both of them in that
Oathkeeper moment so I think of the song
is more of an oath keeper theme which
makes sense now that he's knighting here
rise a knight of the Seven Kingdoms it's
a really interesting book Easter egg
there is that a knight of the seven
kingdoms is a reference to the book
called a knight of the seven kingdoms
which covers the adventures of Duncan
egg the George RR Martin wrote within the
world of A Song of Ice and Fire Brienne
of Tarth is actually related to Sir
Duncan the tall if you couldn't tell
what that Podrick song was - big
surprise twists pod is apparently a
really amazing singer maybe the other
surprise twist is that's what he did to
the girls in the whorehouse so many
seasons ago like what did he do to those
girls that make them love him so much
but the name of the song that he's
singing is called Jenny's song and it's
fabled that the song was always
requested from Jenny by the ghost of the
high heart as payment in exchange for
telling the Brotherhood without banners
of her prophetic dreams so it's kind of
a book easter egg for something that
they didn't really do on the TV show but
obviously the song itself is just really
nice the way they use it during the
episode
I love the transition to the next big
john snowden air scene - as the song is
being sung of this big montage you see
all the different characters and groups
all around the castle you see Daenerys
enter the crypts as Jon Snow is standing
at lyanna stark's statue and she remarks
about Rhaegar Targaryen oh he did all
these terrible things delay on a stark
they said that he was a great singer
obviously referencing the Jenny of
oldstone song that compels Jon Snow to
tell her the truth
and she doesn't believe it almost as
much as Jon Snow didn't believe it he
was a little or quicker to believe what
Sambo was telling him oh your best
friend and your brother told you
something and you're going to believe it
outright it's true I know it's true the
way they're spinning Daenerys his
reaction is that she's thinking more of
it from a succession standpoint oh you
have a claim to the Iron Throne now
you're competing with me for the thing
that I've wanted this whole time even
though I think that they're over blowing
that point a little bit did probably
going to use it as a point of drama between
the two of them for the rest of the
season at least until the last couple of
episodes everything goes wrong for
everyone all at the same time as things
just start spinning out of control as
the White Walkers arrive the horn sounds
the White Walkers arrive but like I said
I think the twist that we're not
expecting here is that the night King
won't even be at this battle it'll just
be his white Walker generals in the army
of the night King will try
to beeline down for King's Landing so
prepare yourself next week we'll be
there Helms Deep
episode is they're calling it Lord of
the Ring style just an episode where
it's nothing but this giant battle going
on the biggest battle in TV history so
it is going to be epic the episode is
going to be way longer than episodes 1 & 2
so I might have to do like a top 20
video but leave all your questions in
the comments below
I'll do an episode 3 trailer video
tomorrow I'm going to giveaway winner when
I post that in a QA video on Tuesday
just like I did last week but while you
wait for everything click here for my
Aria and Gendry season 8 video and click
here for my Game of Thrones season 8
episode 1 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!